It’s 2016, and we’ve seen phonographs,
vinyl, cassette tapes, compact discs, mp3s,
and now… vinyl.
Wait, that can’t be right.
Hey fellow hipsters, Jules here for Dnews.
Vinyl has existed for almost a century, and
over that time, what we think of as “vinyl”
has changed quite a bit.
Some picture gramophone records, but really
vinyl is everywhere!
It’s in your flooring, your t-shirts, your
phone, and depending on your medical history,
it could even be inside your body.
Vinyl can be black, colorful or transparent,
it can be solid or semi-liquid.
It can even be a VERY short lived HBO drama
starring Olivia Wilde.
RIP.
The versatility of vinyl cannot be denied
- but what the hell is it?
Well, vinyl is a plastic made from two basic
compounds: chlorine, which is also found in
salt, and ethylene which is found natural
gas.
These are combined in a chemical reaction
to create ethylene dichloride, which is turned
into a gas, and then, through a process called
“polymerization”, it becomes a fine, white
powder called polyvinyl chloride, or PVC.
Side note: In the United States, we often
use the terms PVC and Vinyl interchangeably,
but in other places, Vinyl refers to specific
applications of the plastic, like flooring
or artificial leather.
Either way, PVC resin is the foundation for
all vinyl.
And perhaps surprisingly it was discovered
by accident... twice.
Two different chemists in the 19th century
left vinyl chlorine gas out in the sun, to
discover that over time it transforms into
a white solid.
After numerous failed attempts to make use
of PVC, an American successfully plasticized
it in the 1920’s and began experimenting
with it as a cheaper and more durable alternative
to rubber and to other plastics.
Initially, the material only made appearances
in random household items like shower curtains,
insulated wire and and rain coats.
Then in the 1930’s PVC manufacturing plants
sprung up, and vinyl made its way into industrial
applications, like gaskets and tubing.
Today, vinyl is manufactured and sold more
than any other plastic in the world, short
of polyethylene..
And, of course, it’s used for records.
But it wasn’t at first.
Originally, records were made from shellac,
another plastic that is today found in fake
nails and wood finish.
However each side of these shellac discs could
only play about 3 or 4 minutes of music, and
record companies realized that if they wanted
a longer playing record, they would need a
tougher material, one that could handle smaller
grooves.
By the 1950’s pretty much all record companies
had switched to vinyl.
So vinyl is, obviously, prolific.
Its durable, recyclable, cheap to manufacture
and can be made into just about anything.
But is it environmentally friendly?
Vinyl manufacturers and trade organizations
say yes, because PVC is mostly made from a
compound based on salt, a natural material,
and it supposedly uses less energy to manufacture
than other plastics.
However, environmentalists and the EPA say
that PVC production releases dioxins and pollutants,
and you could be exposed to them by inhaling
polluted air near manufacturing facilities.
You can also unknowingly intake harmful chemicals
through eating food in pvc-lined packaging
and drinking water transported in pvc pipes.
This could lead to anything from “dizziness,
drowsiness and headaches” to liver damage
and even cancer.
Greenpeace calls vinyl “the most damaging
plastic on the planet” and has also spoken
out about the dangerous toxins it emits when
it’s burned.
Whether vinyl is good or bad, it’s kind
of impossible to avoid.
If it’s not in your clothes or your computer,
is in the walls of your home or lining the
tubes that transport your water.
So maybe just chill.
Put on a record or something…
And while you’re chilling, think of all
the time you’ve wasted not working on your
beach bod.
But don’t get too depressed, it’s not
too late because there’s Beachbody On Demand.
Check them out online at beachbody.com, where
you can get access a wide variety of workout
programs including the world-famous P90X,
Insanity, Focus T25, and many others, ranging
from cardio to resistance training, yoga,
dance, low impact and more.
Sign up for Beachbody On Demand today and
get a FREE 30-Day Membership.
So vinyl is potentially harmful. Are there less harmful plastics?
What about those biodegradable ones? Are those actually good for the environment?
Find out in this video by Trace.
Do you collect vinyl records at home? If so,
what's your favorite ? Let us know down below in the comments
and don't forget to like and subscribe to DNews for more videos every day.